Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
L'Europe risque-t-elle
la panne d'énergie ?
Après deux années de Covid
et la guerre en Ukraine déclenchée,
comme nous le savons, par la Russie
en février 2022,
l'Europe a révélé ses failles :
de véritables béances
dans le domaine
de l'énergie,
de toutes les énergies,
des hydrocarbures au nucléaire
et aux énergies renouvelables.
Pour comprendre
ce désordre énergétique
européen,
d'abord quelques chiffres.
Avant le 24 février 2022,
date de l'invasion russe
de l'Ukraine,
l'Union européenne
dépendait,
dans son mix énergétique,
à près de 60 %
des hydrocarbures,
source d'énergie quasi absente
d'Europe,
et à 12 % du charbon.
Une grande partie
de ces énergies
sont importées de Russie.
Près de 50 %
sont importés de Russie,
en ce qui concerne
le gaz et le charbon.
Depuis que l'embargo a été décrété
vis-à-vis de la Russie,
il ne reste plus
que 9 % du gaz importé.
Si l'on reporte
ce bouquet énergétique,
c'est-à-dire cet ensemble
des énergies,
à la seule électricité
qui représente
le quart de l'énergie primaire,
on observe que le nucléaire
monte à 25 %,
le gaz et le charbon à 33 %
et les énergies renouvelables
à 35 %.
Pardon de ces chiffres,
mais ils sont importants
pour comprendre la politique
énergétique de l'Europe.
On comprend, bien sûr,
le choc constitué
par l'embargo russe
et les difficultés d'autres sources
d'approvisionnement,
dont la brutalité
a été marquée
par un chiffre :
l'augmentation
du coût de l'électricité,
multiplié par quatre,
à partir du coût du gaz,
multiplié par trois.
Nous allons en parler,
bien que ces chiffres
soient en baisse,
aujourd'hui.
Il y a, de surcroît,
des causes endogènes
à l'Europe,
dont les moindres
ne sont pas
la décision brutale
de l'Allemagne en 2011,
- à l'époque,
avec la chancelière Angela Merkel -
de sortir
du nucléaire,
la fermeture, presque partout,
excepté en Europe de l'Est,
des centrales à charbon,
la politique française erratique
concernant sa filière
nucléaire,
un marché européen
de l'électricité
complètement obsolète,
avec des prix sous-évalués,
une insuffisante production
d'énergies renouvelables,
en même temps que
la production de base,
c'est-à-dire celle
qui est disponible à tout moment,
se révélait défaillante.
Bref,
l'Union européenne a failli
dans ce domaine capital
de l'économie mondiale
qui demeure
sous influence politique.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente mes invités.
Christine Goubet-Milhaud,
vous êtes présidente de l'UFE,
c'est-à-dire
l'Union française de l'électricité.
Armand Laferrère,
vous êtes directeur
des Affaires publiques chez Orano.
Erkki Maillard,
vous êtes directeur
des Affaires européennes pour EDF.
Jacques Percebois,
vous êtes professeur émérite
des Universités
et économiste de l'énergie.
Et nous sommes heureux
d'accueillir
Pierre Schellekens
en audioconférence,
et non en visioconférence,
parce que nous avons
un petit problème technique
de transfert d'images.
Je rappelle,
M. Schellekens,
que vous êtes directeur
de l'Energy Policy
au sein
de la Commission européenne.
Première question
qui vient à l'esprit :
l'Europe
de l'énergie,
est-ce que ça n'est pas
un leurre,
au regard de l'expression
des égoïsmes nationaux,
notamment dans le domaine
du mix énergétique
et des sources
variées
d'approvisionnement ?
Christine Goubet-Milhaud.
-Il faut revenir au départ,
au fait que l'unité européenne,
la communauté européenne,
s'est construite sur l'énergie.
Revenons à la CECA.
La CECA, c'est la Communauté
du charbon et de l'acier.
C'est bien une
des premières politiques
que l'Union européenne
a constituées,
dans l'Europe à 6, puis à 27.
Je crois que,
ça, c'est un point important.
Après,
l'énergie est un sujet
éminemment politique.
Les pays ont souhaité garder
un principe de subsidiarité
et la souveraineté
sur leur mix énergétique.
En effet,
c'est un petit peu ça,
la dualité ou la complexité
que nous avons aujourd'hui.
C'est une souveraineté
sur son mix énergétique,
avec les choix de pays
qui sont différents,
mais en même temps
une communauté d'intérêts
sur l'énergie
pour le marché européen,
dans la compétition
internationale.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on doit penser
de cette dualité,
Armand Laferrère ?
Egoïsmes nationaux d'un côté,
politique européenne
de l'énergie
de l'autre.
Est-ce que ça existe ?
-Il faut que ça existe,
pour une raison simple,
c'est que l'Europe est
un plateau énergétique,
avec des interconnexions,
des échanges,
donc c'est bien
un marché de l'énergie.
Ensuite,
c'est dans les traités européens.
Chaque Etat doit
librement décider
de son mix électrique.
Ca n'empêche pas
qu'il faut se coordonner
pour parler des interconnexions,
pour parler des intérêts communs,
pour parler...
Ca n'a pas été assez fait
dans le passé.
Plus exactement,
ça a été fait dans le passé,
mais avec une hypothèse
qui s'est révélée fausse,
qui est qu'on pourrait toujours
se tourner vers la Russie
pour fournir du gaz.
Maintenant qu'on sait
que ça n'est pas le cas,
il faut que la coordination reparte
sur des bases réalistes,
ce qui n'empêchera pas chaque pays
de décider librement de son mix.
-Erkki Maillard,
vous êtes
à Bruxelles,
comme directeur d'EDF
pour les Affaires européennes.
Vous avez le sentiment qu'il y a
une politique énergétique européenne
ou que vous défendez
- c'est votre rôle, d'ailleurs -
la politique française ?
Comment ça s'exprime,
cette dualité ?
-Il y a clairement
des orientations européennes
en matière d'énergie
et dans le domaine climatique.
Traditionnellement,
quand on regarde
les questions énergétiques,
on doit résoudre trois questions
difficiles à réconcilier :
la sécurité énergétique,
le côté propre,
la décarbonation de cette énergie,
et le coût de cette énergie.
Souvent, quand vous traitez
un problème, vous oubliez
une partie de ce triangle.
Ce qu'a fait assez bien
l'Union européenne,
c'est regarder la décarbonation,
avec des objectifs.
Là, il y a une assez bonne unité,
malgré les divergences
en matière de décarbonation.
L'Union européenne veut être
le premier continent
neutre en carbone en 2050.
Sur la partie sécurité énergétique,
comme l'a dit Armand Laferrère,
on s'est reposé
sur des hypothèses
dangereuses.
Non seulement,
sur l'hypothèse de la Russie,
mais en réalité,
ce qu'a révélé la crise
que vous mentionniez au début,
c'est la crise
des énergies fossiles importées.
Vous l'avez dit
dans les chiffres.
C'est parlant.
L'Union européenne,
au-delà de l'électricité,
pour son énergie au sens large,
dépend beaucoup trop
des énergies fossiles importées.
Maintenant,
si on regarde l'avenir,
ce dont l'Europe a besoin,
c'est de développer
ses propres sources
d'énergie,
notamment d'électricité,
qui soient à la fois décarbonées,
disponibles
et pas trop chères.
-M. Schellekens,
vous, vous êtes,
j'allais dire, Dr Europe.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ?
Je ne vous cache pas que,
dans les différents pays européens,
on critique beaucoup
ce qu'est supposée être
une politique énergétique
européenne.
A votre avis, elle existe
ou ce sont les égoïsmes nationaux
qui se disputent
dans ce domaine ?
*-Je ne vais pas vous étonner,
en vous disant que
je ne partage pas tout à fait
le constat de départ,
d'introduction de l'émission,
et ceci pour deux raisons
principales.
Parce que je crois
que l'Union européenne
et les Etats membres,
non seulement
les structures étatiques,
mais aussi les entreprises,
la société au sens large,
sont en train de faire face
à un choc très important.
Vous l'avez vous-même énoncé.
Le fait de passer
en quelques mois
d'une importation de gaz russe
qui représentait 40-45 %
de l'importation totale
à, aujourd'hui,
7 %, plus ou moins,
c'est un choc pour le système
énergétique, évidemment,
mais nous nous retrouvons surtout
dans une situation,
aujourd'hui, en décembre 2022,
avec des stocks
qui sont bien remplis,
avec une diversification
des importations.
Alors, tout n'est
certainement pas parfait.
Les prix restent volatils.
Ils restent à un niveau élevé,
même si,
comme vous le disiez,
ils ont tendance à chuter,
ces derniers temps.
Mais le simple fait
que nous pouvons rentrer
dans l'hiver 2021...
2022-2023, pardon.
De façon relativement sereine,
en termes de sécurité
et d'approvisionnement...
-C'est moins assuré
pour 2023-2024.
*-Je suis complètement d'accord.
Justement, maintenant,
nos mesures s'orientent surtout
et avant tout
sur l'hiver prochain,
en effet, 2023-2024.
Vous avez vu ce qu'on a fait,
la législation,
par exemple,
sur la plateforme d'achat conjointe.
C'est justement très orienté
pour l'hiver prochain.
-Merci.
Jacques Percebois,
tout le monde a souligné
une augmentation des prix.
Est-ce que vous pouvez expliquer,
justement,
cette chose-là ?
Pourquoi il y a une indexation
du coût du kilowattheure
d'électricité sur le gaz ?
D'où cet effet,
si vous voulez,
de multiplication
des coûts de l'électricité
à partir des coûts du gaz.
Sans rentrer
dans des détails techniques,
mais pour les téléspectateurs.
-Les pays de l'Union européenne
ont en commun
la confiance
dans les mécanismes du marché.
Dans le domaine de l'électricité,
on a mis un marché interconnecté
entre les différents pays européens.
Sur le marché,
le prix d'équilibre
se fait en fonction
du coût des différentes
centrales appelées.
On appelle
les centrales électriques
en fonction des coûts
qui sont croissants,
des coûts marginaux croissants,
de fonctionnement croissants.
La dernière centrale
appelée en ce moment
est une centrale
à gaz.
Les centrales thermiques,
comme les centrales à gaz
ou à charbon,
sont des centrales pour lesquelles
le coût du combustible
est un élément constitutif
important.
Le prix du gaz s'est envolé.
Par ricochet, le prix
de l'électricité s'est envolé,
car il est aligné
sur le coût de fonctionnement
de la dernière centrale,
qui est à gaz.
Donc on n'a pas
volontairement indexé
le prix de l'électricité
sur celui du gaz.
C'est le fonctionnement du marché
qui fait ça.
Le problème, c'est que, ce marché,
c'est comme un système d'enchères.
Tout le monde est payé
au même niveau,
c'est-à-dire au prix limite,
au prix d'équilibre,
le prix que reçoit
la dernière centrale.
Vous avez des centrales
qui reçoivent des rentes
relativement importantes.
-Très simplement...
La France souhaiterait qu'on sorte
de cette relation mécanique.
L'Allemagne ne veut pas.
Pourquoi la France veut-elle sortir
et pourquoi
l'Allemagne refuse ?
-C'est pas vraiment ça.
C'est simplement que
la France propose une mesure
qui est très proche de la mesure
proposée par l'Espagne.
Le constat est le suivant :
puisque la faute revient
à un prix du gaz qui est élevé,
subventionnons le gaz
qui est utilisé
pour la production
d'électricité.
Mécaniquement,
le prix de l'électricité chutera.
On l'a vu en Espagne.
Mais ça pose des difficultés.
Les Allemands n'en veulent pas,
d'abord,
parce que ça leur coûterait
plus cher.
Ils auraient plus de gaz
à subventionner.
Ensuite, parce qu'une partie
de l'électricité
qu'ils fabriquent
avec le gaz
est exportée vers la France,
aux heures de pointe.
Ils proposent d'autres mesures.
Mais la France
ne veut pas sortir
du marché, en l'état actuel.
Elle veut simplement proposer
des correctifs.
On constate que
tous les pays ne sont pas
sur la même longueur d'onde.
Il y a d'autres solutions,
d'ailleurs.
-Erkki Maillard, oui ?
-Il faut distinguer
court terme et long terme.
A court terme, comme l'a dit
le professeur Percebois,
il y a un débat :
faut-il mettre un plafond
au prix du gaz qu'on utilise
pour faire de l'électricité ?
C'est la seule façon efficace
de lutter contre l'inflation.
A long terme,
il y a un autre problème :
comment rémunérer
les investissements faits ?
Pour une entreprise
comme EDF,
l'objectif n'est pas
de tondre les clients,
quand les prix sont élevés.
C'est de rémunérer
ces investissements
avec des prix proches
du coût moyen à long terme
de l'investissement.
Le problème qu'on a,
c'est que le système,
qui est efficace pour assurer,
au jour le jour, à court terme,
la sécurité,
pour que l'offre,
la production d'électricité
rencontre la demande en électricité,
ne donne pas
le bon signal de prix
pour couvrir
le coût des investissements.
Juste pour terminer.
C'est un problème, quand vous avez
la France qui investit
dans des moyens décarbonés.
C'est là où, politiquement,
il peut y avoir une difficulté.
Pourquoi
est-ce que
le consommateur français,
le contribuable français,
accepterait un système où le prix
de l'électricité
est couplé...
Il n'est pas indexé.
Il est couplé au gaz,
alors qu'on investit
dans des sources
décarbonées.
Ce sont deux sujets distincts,
le court terme
et le long terme.
-M. Schellekens,
sans polémiquer, si vous voulez,
avec la Direction générale
de l'énergie
et la Commission européenne,
il se dit, en France,
que dans ce domaine-là...
Bien sûr, j'ai exagéré
le différend franco-allemand.
Il se dit que
l'influence allemande prédomine
et que c'est la raison
pour laquelle on ne bouge pas
de ce mécanisme
qui relie gaz et électricité.
Qu'est-ce que vous répondez,
M. Schellekens ?
*-Il ne s'agit pas de ça.
Mais comme il a été dit,
le marché électrique européen
a beaucoup de points...
Il a beaucoup de points forts.
Il nous a assuré,
pendant des années,
un système
en équilibre
qui nous fournissait une sécurité
d'approvisionnement.
Ce marché,
il ne faut pas l'oublier,
est important en période de crise
pour justement équilibrer
l'offre et la demande
au niveau européen.
Sans ce marché européen,
nous aurions eu des problèmes
d'approvisionnement
bien plus pointus,
en tout cas, dans certains pays,
dans certaines régions.
Par contre,
nous sommes d'accord.
Il y a besoin de revoir
certains points bien précis.
C'est un travail qui est lancé
par la Commission.
Nous présenterons déjà ça
à la fin de cette année,
une consultation publique,
puis une révision rapide,
prévue pour début 2023,
une révision ciblée,
notamment
sur plusieurs objectifs,
sur ce qui vient d'être dit,
sur comment faire en sorte
que les consommateurs aient
les bénéfices du fait
que le renouvelable augmente
sa contribution
à l'approvisionnement
en électricité,
mais aussi sur ces signaux
d'investissement
qui sont en effet très importants.
La transparence du marché,
l'intégrité du marché,
ce sont justement des paramètres
de notre révision du système
qui est prévue pour 2023.
-Mais M. Schellekens,
est-ce qu'il y a une position
de la Commission
sur une dissociation
du prix de l'électricité
à partir...
de la dernière centrale à gaz ?
Est-ce qu'on peut...
Vous avez une position
là-dessus ?
On sait quelle est
la position de la France.
la position de l'Allemagne.
Est-ce qu'il y a une position
de la Commission européenne ?
*-Ca reste un sujet...
Ca reste un sujet
que nous creusons,
dans le contexte de cette révision.
Je ne peux pas en parler
plus en détail.
Dans le contexte
de cette révision,
c'est un des sujets
que nous creusons.
Par exemple, le système,
disons, ibérique
a été validé à la Commission
dans le contexte
hispano-portugais,
donc il est passé
par une validation à la Commission.
Mais dans le contexte de révision
du marché de l'électricité,
il y a surtout ce paramètre,
qui est de dire :
comment est-ce que nous garantissons
un équilibre du marché,
tout en ayant
une vraie protection
des consommateurs
et une transparence ?
-"Wait and see".
On attend la fin de l'année
pour voir...
*-Ah non,
ce n'est pas "wait and see".
Pour vous peut-être,
mais pour nous,
c'est beaucoup de travail.
-D'accord. Ecoutez...
Vous voulez dire un mot,
Christine Goubet-Milhaud.
-Il faut distinguer
le court terme
et le moyen-long terme,
comme ça a été dit.
Sur le court terme,
le cadre de marché européen
nous a rendu des grands services
dans les années passées
et reste nécessaire,
parce que si on veut,
avec des interconnexions,
s'échanger
de l'électricité décarbonée,
il faut bien qu'il y ait
un prix qui soit fixé,
dont tout le monde convient...
Alors, c'est le prix
de la dernière centrale appelée
pour le court terme,
pour équilibrer
l'offre et la demande
au niveau du système européen.
Là où il y a un sujet
plus structurel,
c'est pourquoi ce prix
de court terme,
d'ajustement presque journalier,
au niveau européen,
serait celui qui déterminerait
le prix auquel,
dans la durée,
on achète et on se projette.
Quand on est un industriel...
Au-delà
des ménages et de la volatilité
sur le pouvoir d'achat,
il y a la question de l'industrie.
Comment investir,
si on ne sait pas
quel sera le prix
dans un mois, dans un an
ou dans deux ans ?
Ce qui manque, en fait,
c'est une visibilité
du prix de l'électricité
sur des contrats plus longs.
Ca, c'est vraiment
absolument important.
C'est ma première remarque.
Ma deuxième remarque,
c'est que, dans cette crise,
je pense qu'il faut aussi imaginer
que l'inflation à laquelle
les pays européens font face
est liée en partie
à l'énergie
et aux problématiques
dont nous débattons, là,
mais il y a un autre sujet
qui se cache derrière ça.
C'est le prix des intrants
industriels de nos industries
où, finalement, c'est le prix...
C'est pas le prix des électrons,
mais c'est le prix de l'énergie
que nous ne produisons pas
sur notre sol européen,
mais qui subit aussi
un renchérissement
qui est aussi
en train de pénaliser
l'industrie européenne et française
dans la compétition internationale.
Derrière l'inflation tirée
par les prix,
- et nous avons à répondre
à cette question pour trouver
des solutions européennes -
il y a aussi la question
d'une inflation tirée
par l'énergie
que nous ne produisons pas,
par les intrants
des biens industriels
de notre industrie européenne.
-Merci.
Armand Laferrère,
vous avez entendu
ce qui vient d'être dit.
Ca pénalise
notre industrialisation
qui en a vraiment besoin,
mais quand même,
il faut aussi regarder
la situation française.
Il y a quand même eu
une imprévoyance
de la France,
en ce qui concerne
ces besoins d'énergie,
notamment
d'électricité.
Pourquoi cette imprévoyance ?
Elle existe.
-Non, je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse dire ça.
Ce qui est vrai,
c'est que, aujourd'hui,
la France,
mais l'Europe aussi,
puisqu'on parle de l'Europe...
C'est apparemment
le titre de l'émission.
Elles ne peuvent pas se passer
d'une réflexion stratégique
sur l'avenir.
Il va falloir investir.
Il va falloir investir
dans de nouvelles
capacités de production,
de distribution et d'interconnexion.
Investir, c'est les entreprises
qui le font.
C'est les industries.
Elles ne peuvent
le faire
que si elles ont de la visibilité.
Au niveau beaucoup plus européen
que français,
contrairement
à ce que vous dites,
il va falloir accepter que,
pour rendre possibles
les investissements,
il ne faut pas penser
qu'en termes de marché.
Il faut raisonner
en termes de capacités
à avoir des contrats à long terme,
à stabiliser
les prix
et en termes de capacités
à réfléchir à un plan stratégique
d'échelonnement des investissements.
L'Europe a été très utile
pour mettre en place
un marché commun,
mais quand on parle de masse
d'investissements à faire,
les entreprises ont besoin
de savoir où elles vont,
donc il faut tempérer
cette volonté
de faire fonctionner le marché
par une volonté de rendre
les investissements possibles.
-Oui, Jacques Percebois ?
-La décarbonation
du mix électrique européen
va s'accompagner
d'un développement massif
de centrales,
nucléaires ou renouvelables,
pour lesquelles on a
des coûts fixes élevés
par rapport
aux coûts de fonctionnement,
à l'inverse
des centrales thermiques,
à gaz ou à charbon,
pour lesquelles ce sont
les coûts de fonctionnement
qui sont élevés.
-Car l'uranium
entre pour très peu dans le prix
d'une centrale nucléaire.
-5 %. Par conséquent,
ce qu'il faut voir,
c'est qu'à court terme,
le marché est très volatil,
et il est fondé sur les coûts
de fonctionnement.
Pour le long terme,
on a besoin
d'investir.
Il faut pouvoir financer
les coûts fixes.
Cette seule solution
sur le long terme,
c'est des contrats à long terme
qui permettent de couvrir
les coûts complets
des centrales
et qui envoient un signal stable
aux consommateurs,
notamment industriels.
Ca n'exclut pas qu'on maintienne
un marché de gros
pour le court terme,
mais il faut revoir le modèle
pour le moyen-long terme.
-Ecoutez, il y a quand même
des problèmes en France.
Si on prend
la capacité théorique
de production
d'électricité,
plus de 60 gigawatts,
la filière nucléaire française
est en mesure de produire ça,
mais aujourd'hui,
elle en produit à peine 40.
Alors,
qu'est-ce qui a flanché,
M. Erkki Maillard ?
-De façon conjoncturelle,
il y a la rencontre
de deux problèmes très différents.
Il y a les effets à retardement
de la crise du Covid,
qui font qu'on fait toujours
des arrêts sur les centrales
pour faire de la maintenance.
-Ca tombe mal !
-Je ne dis pas le contraire.
Ca tombe mal, effectivement.
Et puis,
il y a par ailleurs
la découverte d'un phénomène
qui était inattendu.
A l'occasion d'un contrôle,
on a trouvé,
sur certains circuits
des centrales,
ce qu'on appelle
de la corrosion,
des microfissures,
qu'il faut traiter.
Il n'y a rien
de dramatique.
C'est une solution qui a été validée
par l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire,
mais comme vous le dites,
ça ne tombe pas bien.
-Est-ce que vous pouvez
rassurer les Français en leur disant
quand est-ce que la filière
nucléaire française
travaillera à plein régime ?
-Elle travaille à plein régime,
que ce soit Orano ou EDF.
-Oui, mais elle ne produit pas
60 gigawatts.
-Non, mais elle est
tous les jours au travail
pour mettre le plus de tranches
possible sur le réseau.
Ca, c'est l'aspect de court terme,
évidemment, qui est très important,
puisque c'est le passage
de cet hiver.
Si on regarde à long terme,
comme ça a été dit,
il va falloir investir
dans des capacités
de production
d'électricité décarbonée.
C'est quoi ?
Ce sont le vent et le soleil,
l'éolien et le solaire.
Il ne faut pas oublier
l'hydraulique,
très utile,
parce qu'on peut stocker.
Et puis,
c'est du nucléaire.
C'est important que,
à l'échelle de l'UE,
on accepte la totalité
de ces technologies,
qu'il n'y en ait pas une
qui soit privilégiée,
parce que, sinon,
le marché se retrouve biaisé.
A cette condition,
si on a des signaux de long terme,
si les investisseurs ont un signal
de prix de long terme,
si les clients eux-mêmes,
qui vont acheter l'électricité,
voient à long terme
et si les technologies bas carbone
peuvent y contribuer,
à ce moment-là, on pourra sortir
des fossiles importés
qui créent
la crise actuelle.
C'est pas les difficultés
conjoncturelles
du parc français.
C'est le prix du gaz
que nous importons.
Là, on a substitué...
Il fallait le faire.
On a substitué du gaz américain
au gaz russe, ou d'autres pays.
Mais il faut,
et la Commission y travaille,
faire plus d'énergies renouvelables
et plus de nucléaire.
Beaucoup d'Etats membres
le souhaitent.
-M. Schellekens, je voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus.
Vous avez entendu que,
disons,
les problèmes du marché
de l'électricité
pénalisent la réindustrialisation
ou l'industrialisation de la France.
Est-ce que c'est vrai,
cette idée
qu'on entend à Paris,
à savoir que
Bruxelles préfère financer
des renouvelables
que le nucléaire ?
*-Ecoutez, nous, on a...
Comme ça a été dit
au début de l'émission,
le mix énergétique appartient
à chaque Etat membre,
donc la Commission
ne prend pas position
pour une forme...
Une forme d'énergie.
Ce qui se passe,
c'est qu'il y a une augmentation
- les chiffres sont impressionnants
pour 2022
et le seront probablement
pour 2023 -
en termes d'expansion
du renouvelable,
notamment du solaire.
L'année 2022 sera
une année record
pour l'expansion du renouvelable
en Europe,
ce qui, d'ailleurs,
contribue
à remplacer le gaz russe aussi.
On ne le remplace pas uniquement
avec du gaz américain
ou du gaz d'autres sources.
Alors, il y a une vraie...
Une vraie stratégie
d'aller vers le renouvelable.
J'ajouterais une autre dimension
à votre discussion.
Il y a, en effet,
le besoin d'investissement,
le besoin de stabilité
et d'augmenter la capacité
de production,
- on est d'accord -
mais il y a aussi un volet demande,
de maîtrise de la demande.
Là, je ne parle pas
d'une destruction
de la demande.
Ce n'est certainement pas
l'objectif.
Il y a des mesures
d'efficacité énergétique,
ce qui nous a permis,
d'ailleurs,
cette réduction de la demande,
à rentrer dans cet hiver
avec les stocks bien remplis.
On a été chercher le gaz autre part,
mais on a aussi réduit
notre consommation.
-On a beaucoup parlé
de la guerre en Ukraine,
et notamment des problèmes
de l'électricité et du gaz,
mais tous les problèmes
ne viennent pas de la Russie.
Armand Laferrère,
l'Allemagne a proposé d'injecter
200 milliards d'euros
dans son économie
pour soutenir, notamment,
la transition énergétique.
Pourquoi
cela a-t-il été mal vu en France
et critiqué
en France ?
C'était un cavalier seul,
comme aurait dit Richelieu ?
-Si on veut,
parce que, comme on l'a dit,
les pays sont interconnectés,
donc...
Si le secteur énergétique allemand
fonctionne mieux,
ça n'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les autres.
Ce qui aurait été
une meilleure nouvelle,
c'est qu'ils n'arrêtent pas
leurs centrales nucléaires.
On ne serait pas
dans la pénurie d'aujourd'hui.
C'est, à mon avis,
plutôt ces décisions anciennes
qui sont contestables
que les décisions récentes
qui sont une réponse
à une situation de crise.
Si on avait 200 milliards
à dépenser, on ferait pareil.
C'est une réponse
de circonstance
qu'on ne peut pas leur reprocher.
-On ne peut pas le leur reprocher,
mais peut-on reprocher,
M. Schellekens,
à la Pologne d'avoir choisi
la technologie nucléaire
de Westinghouse
pour construire
sa première centrale nucléaire,
alors que ce pays reçoit
une aide financière massive
de l'Union européenne
pour financer notamment
sa transition énergétique ?
Monsieur Schellekens.
*-Déjà, le gouvernement polonais
est libre de ses décisions,
nous ne sommes pas...
L'union Européenne n'est pas
une corporation où nous forçons
les gouvernements à prendre...
à choisir des technologies
ou à conclure certains contrats.
Donc ça, franchement,
pour le moment,
la Commission européenne
reste hors de ce débat.
Nous, la stratégie,
surtout,
c'est avant tout se défaire
d'une dépendance envers la Russie.
Et ça, c'est... c'est...
ce qui reste l'objet
principal de nos débats.
-Oui, mais monsieur Schellekens,
derrière ma question,
il y a une sous-question,
si vous voulez.
*-J'avais cru comprendre, oui.
-Vous avez cru comprendre,
je vais essayer de l'expliciter.
Certains disent
que la Pologne est allée
vers l'achat
de cette technologie américaine
parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de financement européen
pour construire une centrale
nucléaire en Pologne.
Est-ce que c'est exact ?
Est-ce que ça aurait pu se faire ?
Parce que, le problème,
la France n'a pas, on le sait,
la France a une belle
filière nucléaire
mais sa trésorerie, peut-être,
n'autorise pas aujourd'hui
de financement de nouvelles
centrales à l'extérieur.
Est-ce que l'Europe peut
suppléer à cette chose-là ?
*-En principe,
le budget européen,
les instruments financiers
que nous avons ne financent pas
la construction de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires.
Les ressources financières,
dans ce domaine,
de l'Union Européenne,
se concentrent surtout
sur la sécurité nucléaire
et aussi, ces dernières années,
depuis en fait 10 ou 15 ans,
sur les mesures pour...
Je crois que le terme français
est la décom...
-Le démantèlement.
*-Le démantèlement, merci,
le démantèlement
de certaines centrales
de type encore soviétique,
qu'il y avait en Bulgarie,
en Lituanie et je crois
aussi en Slovaquie.
Donc voilà votre réponse.
-Jacques Percebois,
ça vous satisfait,
ce que vous entendez,
que l'Europe ne peut pas
contrer qu'un pays européen
se dirige dans ces achats,
majeurs,
puisqu'une centrale nucléaire,
ça n'est pas un magasin
d'alimentation,
vers les Etats-Unis
plutôt que vers l'Europe ?
Et, à votre avis,
y a-t-il moyen de faire autrement ?
-Chaque pays est souverain
dans ce domaine,
la politique énergétique
étant nationale,
la Pologne a le droit
de choisir Westinghouse.
Simplement, on voit bien que,
sur le nucléaire, y a une bataille
au sein des pays
européens très forte.
On peut citer la taxonomie,
c'est en effet
une liste, en quelque sorte,
d'investissements
qui peuvent être aidés
indirectement ou directement
par l'Union Européenne.
C'est vrai que, là, y a une bataille
franco-allemande importante,
les Allemands refusant le nucléaire,
l'acceptant in fine à condition
qu'on y mette aussi le gaz,
ce qui, sur une liste
de produits décarbonés,
n'est pas la meilleure solution.
Maintenant,
chaque pays étant souverain,
et la Pologne, il y a des raisons
politiques qui jouent
un rôle important,
notamment des raisons militaires,
des raisons liées
évidemment au choix
de la centrale américaine.
-Oui, Erkki Maillard ?
-Sur ce cas polonais,
deux remarques :
d'abord, il y a toujours
une offre française sur la table,
il est pas dit que les Polonais
ne choisissent pas aussi une autre
technologie,
c'est important de le redire,
et je pense que...
-Pardonnez-moi,
juste une précision :
dans l'offre
française,
est-ce qu'il y a aussi
un projet de financement ?
-Alors, y a toujours,
quand y a une proposition
de vente de centrale,
y a un dialogue avec le client
pour savoir comment financer et,
généralement,
y a une part de capital apportée
par le client, l'investisseur,
et une part de dette,
qui peut être aussi
du crédit-export.
Donc dans le cas de l'offre
faite pour la Pologne, oui,
y a aussi un volet financement.
Et la question que vous avez posée
à ce sujet est très importante.
On voit aujourd'hui
les Etats-Unis proposer de financer
les études de faisabilité
de réacteurs en Europe,
avec de l'argent américain,
évidemment pour de la technologie
américaine.
Et ça, ça pose question.
A l'inverse,
y a encore un débat,
qui sera peut-être tranché
dans le bon sens,
pour savoir si on peut utiliser
les fonds de relance,
par exemple les fonds REPowerEU,
qui est un des fonds
européens,
non seulement pour faire
des énergies renouvelables,
de l'efficacité énergétique,
et ces deux choses
sont indispensables,
mais aussi pour faire du nucléaire.
C'est nécessaire.
-Est-ce que vous êtes aussi présent
sur un appel d'offre
en République tchèque ?
-Absolument,
alors c'est un système
et un réacteur qui est différent,
mais absolument,
EDF se positionne aussi
pour présenter
un réacteur en République tchèque.
Ce qui est intéressant,
dans ces deux seuls exemples,
c'est qu'il y a en ce moment
des Etats-membres qui veulent
faire du nucléaire
alors qu'ils n'en faisaient pas
et d'autres
qui disent que pour atteindre
la neutralité carbone en 2050
et pour assurer la sécurité
énergétique à long terme,
ils veulent
combiner des énergies
renouvelables intermittentes
et du nucléaire.
Il faut entendre ça et il faut,
objectivement, aujourd'hui,
il n'y a pas d'égalité de traitement
entre les énergies décarbonées.
Mon propos n'est pas de dire
qu'il faut privilégier
l'un ou l'autre
mais bien les traiter.
C'est pas un débat nucléaire
contre renouvelables,
on a besoin des deux pour faire
plus d'électricité décarbonée
et pour décarboner l'économie,
les transports, le bâtiment, etc.,
tout en réduisant,
et la Commission l'a dit,
il faut réduire bien sûr la demande.
-Christine Goubet-Milhaud,
vous voulez intervenir ?
-Je voudrais prendre un peu de recul
sur cette crise que nous vivons
et qui nous rappelle
que l'énergie a une valeur,
que cette énergie,
quelle qu'elle soit,
mais encore plus
les énergies fossiles
puisqu'on a l'ambition d'en sortir,
nous devons l'économiser,
donc la question de la demande,
des économies d'énergie,
en électricité
comme en gaz,
comme en pétrole,
devient un sujet-clef,
un peu comme dans les années 70,
après le premier choc pétrolier,
rappelons-nous l'histoire,
et cette crise
est peut-être pas la dernière,
car en fait,
la volatilité des sources importées,
nous la subissons.
Alors nous subissons effectivement
la volatilité du prix du gaz,
datant d'avant la guerre en Ukraine,
ça avait commencé fin 2022
avec la reprise
de la croissance en Chine.
Donc le marché mondial du gaz
est un marché extrêmement
concurrentiel,
on va le voir aussi
au niveau du LNG.
Donc y a une concurrence,
donc la volatilité
des énergies importées
est intrinsèque,
d'où la nécessité d'investir
sur notre territoire national,
notre territoire européen,
dans une approche pragmatique,
c'est-à-dire technology neutral,
tout ce qui est décarboné
va dans le bon sens,
le nucléaire,
les EnR, et même si les pays
choisissent leur mix,
ça reste l'affaire de l'Europe,
le nucléaire n'est pas
que l'affaire de la France,
si elle fait le choix de relancer
un programme nucléaire,
c'est l'affaire de l'Europe.
L'Europe, dans ces complémentarités
du système électrique interconnecté,
doit pouvoir exporter, importer,
dans les moments de tension.
D'ailleurs, la France,
nous avons exporté du nucléaire
dans toute l'Europe des années.
Aujourd'hui, nous importons
peut-être de l'énergie
produite à partir de charbon
dans la période conjoncturelle
que nous vivons,
mais effectivement,
nous devons considérer
que la meilleure garantie
contre la crise,
c'est d'investir
des capacités sur le territoire
pour sortir d'une dépendance.
-Alors, Armand Laferrère,
y a une question un peu idéologique
qui se pose :
on parle
du nucléaire,
on parle des énergies
renouvelables,
mais les énergies fossiles
sont là et utiles,
encore,
un certain nombre d'années,
le charbon revient,
dans de nombreux pays,
est-ce que les pays de l'OPEP,
qui ont profité,
en quelque sorte, de la crise
énergétique européenne
pour augmenter considérablement
le prix du baril de pétrole,
est-ce que ça vous paraît logique
avec une politique
de coopération internationale
ou est-ce que vous y voyez plutôt
l'égoïsme des nations
et une espèce
de stratégie anti-occidentale
à ce niveau ?
Parce qu'on a vu que l'Afrique,
d'une certaine manière,
s'est rapprochée de la Russie,
la Russie, la Chine,
toutes ces puissances,
si vous voulez, émergentes,
et non démocratiques.
Est-ce que les pays de l'OPEP
n'ont pas profité
de cette conjoncture
pour avancer
leurs pions et, à leur tour,
s'engager, quelque part ?
-Qu'il y ait des rivalités
géopolitiques
et que les blocs civilisationnels
ne s'aiment pas,
rivalisent entre eux,
essaient de se dominer
les uns les autres,
ça a toujours été le cas,
c'est normal,
il ne s'agit pas
de le leur reprocher.
Ce qu'il s'agirait de faire,
c'est qu'en Occident,
plus exactement
en Europe,
car l'Amérique a une problématique
très différente,
nous fassions
la même chose.
Nous avons des intérêts,
qui se trouvent être
les intérêts de la planète
sur un point important,
c'est le besoin de moins
d'énergies fossiles
pour des raisons géopolitiques
et c'est également bon
pour la planète.
Donc que les Européens
arrêtent de se disputer entre eux
sur la nature des énergies
décarbonées à construire
et qu'ils se mettent
à en construire, toutes.
Et effectivement...
-Même des centrales
à charbon ?
-Non,
des énergies décarbonées,
j'ai dit.
Les énergies décarbonées.
L'objectif et le mérite
de l'Europe sont...
-Oui, mais vous répondez pas
à ma question :
est-ce que ces pays de l'OPEP,
en augmentant le coût du baril,
n'ont pas...
ne sont pas allés vers une démarche
anti-occidentale ?
-Ils voulaient avoir plus d'argent,
ce que n'importe qui ferait
à leur place.
Que derrière, bien sûr...
-Ils ont cherché
à profiter de la crise ?
-Sauf que,
je suis même pas si sûr parce que,
regardez, les pays de l'OPEP,
ça n'est pas une unité.
Le plus gros producteur de pétrole,
l'Arabie saoudite,
est un allié de l'Occident,
du point de vue géopolitique,
d'autres effectivement
ne nous aiment pas beaucoup.
Mais le point commun
qu'ils ont,
c'est qu'ils veulent maximiser
leurs revenus.
Et nous, notre intérêt,
c'est de faire en sorte de n'avoir
pas besoin d'eux,
ou le moins possible, et pour ça,
les Européens doivent arrêter
de se disputer
et construire du décarboné,
du renouvelable, du nucléaire,
sans en faire un sujet
pour le coup idéologique.
Parce que l'idéologie
antinucléaire en Europe
me paraît beaucoup plus gênante
que l'idéologie anti-occidentale
qui forcément existe
dans la partie du monde
qui n'est pas l'Occident.
-Erkki Maillard,
y a un paradoxe : d'un côté,
les pays de l'OPEP augmentent
le coût du baril de pétrole
et vous, vous ne pouvez pas
augmenter le prix
de l'électricité et même,
vous le vendez
à un prix sous-évalué.
Une entreprise
comme ça ne peut pas
garantir sa solvabilité financière.
Pourquoi ?
Et que faut-il faire ?
-Ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure,
la clef, pour une entreprise
qui investit dans des capacités
de production qui vont durer
40 ans, 60 ans, voire plus,
c'est de pouvoir couvrir
le coût de cet investissement
sur cette durée.
Ca veut dire plus
de contrats à long terme
avec les clients ou avec les Etats,
ça veut dire aussi qu'on doit
réduire le coût des financements,
car ces investissements
requièrent beaucoup
de capitaux, pour les centrales
hydrauliques, nucléaires,
et donc y a des modèles
qui permettent de réduire ce coût,
donc in fine
le coût pour le consommateur.
Donc on a besoin de ces deux choses
et puis on a besoin
d'un peu de visibilité
quand même sur le mix, à long terme,
et c'est vrai que c'est
de la responsabilité
des Etats-membres,
mais avec une dimension européenne.
On ne peut pas, par exemple,
se reposer entièrement
sur les interconnexions pour dire :
si j'ai pas assez
de capacités, un jour,
je vais importer de mon voisin,
d'à côté, à gauche ou à droite.
Donc y a à un moment
besoin au niveau européen
que les Etats, la Commission,
les gestionnaires
de réseaux regardent
la planification
énergétique pour dire
si on a assez de capacités ou pas.
-Monsieur Maillard,
la question que je vous pose,
c'est pourquoi EDF a accepté
le principe de l'ARENH,
qui est un prix sous-évalué ?
Est-ce qu'il fallait pas
le refuser d'emblée ?
-Vous posez une question
qui en fait s'adresse
plus aux régulateurs,
à l'Etat.
EDF prend
la réglementation qu'on lui propose.
Mais votre question...
-Mais ça a fragilisé
l'entreprise.
-Votre question,
elle met le doigt sur le point-clef
qui est avoir des prix
qui couvrent les coûts
des investissements.
Effectivement,
pendant longtemps,
y compris parce que
l'énergie était pas chère
et que ça satisfaisait
beaucoup de gens,
en Europe et ailleurs,
on a imaginé
qu'il était,
qu'on pouvait vivre avec des prix
durablement très bas et, en réalité,
y a eu un sous-investissement
et aujourd'hui, on en paie le prix.
On a fait des erreurs,
collectivement.
-Jacques Percebois,
l'ARENH était une bêtise ?
-L'ARENH,
sur le principe,
s'explique par le contexte
dans lequel le mécanisme a été
mis en place.
C'est une loi qui a fixé l'ARENH,
je dirais, en 2010.
-Dites en quoi ça consiste.
-L'ARENH, ça consiste,
pour permettre aux concurrents d'EDF
de gagner des parts de marché,
n'ayant pas l'avantage du nucléaire,
ça obligeait EDF à vendre
une partie de sa production,
à l'époque 25 %,
car EDF produisait
plus de 400 térawattheures
et l'ARENH, c'était limité
à 100 térawattheures.
EDF avait l'obligation, par la loi,
c'est pas un choix d'EDF,
de vendre une partie
de son nucléaire
à prix coûtant.
Simplement, ce qui était prévu,
c'est que ce fameux prix,
qui était au départ fixé
à 42 euros le mégawattheure
au 1er janvier 2012,
devait évoluer dans le temps
en tenant compte de l'inflation,
des coûts nouveaux
que le nucléaire allait supporter.
Bon, le système a pas été respecté,
y a eu un effet pervers.
C'est vrai aujourd'hui
que le nucléaire
historique, je dirais,
récupère à peu près ses fonds,
mais EDF vend
son nucléaire historique
à un prix qui est très en dessous
du prix de gros,
du prix du marché.
C'est là où y a un manque
à gagner pour EDF.
Ceci étant, ce système permet
quand même, il faut le souligner,
au consommateur
particulier et même
au consommateur industriel
de bénéficier d'un prix
relativement stable.
Aujourd'hui, si le consommateur
français, domestique,
a eu une augmentation de 4 %
en 2022, c'est grâce au mécanisme
de l'ARENH, bien évidemment.
-Christine Goubet-Milhaud ?
-En fait, l'ARENH résulte
de la loi NOME de 2010,
c'est une loi, hein,
c'est pas les acteurs
économiques qui ont décidé,
et la philosophie de départ,
c'était de dire :
les consommateurs ont le droit
de changer de fournisseur,
c'est l'ouverture des marchés,
et quel que soit le fournisseur,
ils bénéficient
de l'investissement historique
de la France dans le nucléaire.
C'est juste une petite nuance :
c'est les consommateurs
français qui ont le droit,
quel que soit leur fournisseur,
de bénéficier du nucléaire existant.
La question qui se pose aujourd'hui,
c'est de savoir
comment on va financer
les nouveaux programmes,
c'est-à-dire le futur,
puisque finalement les centrales
nucléaires existantes,
on pourra les prolonger
10 ou 15 ans mais, au-delà de ça,
nous devons préparer l'avenir
de la France en termes
de mix électrique décarboné
pour nos enfants
et nos petits-enfants,
donc 2045, 2050.
C'est demain,
à l'échelle du temps industriel.
-Mais l'ARENH ne prévoyait pas
le financement du nouveau nucléaire,
c'était très clair.
Le législateur a dit :
tous les consommateurs
ayant participé
au financement
du nucléaire historique,
ils sont légitimes
de profiter du mécanisme.
Le nouveau nucléaire,
ce sont de nouvelles questions.
-Brièvement ?
-L'ARENH, telle qu'elle est,
c'est un poison
pour une entreprise comme EDF.
-Voilà, vous le dites.
-Bien sûr,
mais c'est l'affaire du législateur.
Oui, c'est un poison,
quand vous êtes une entreprise
et que vous ne pouvez pas
vendre le produit que vous produisez
au bon tarif et que,
lentement, vous perdez de l'argent,
effectivement,
c'est pas une bonne chose,
si vous vouliez cette réponse.
-Vous voyez la citation
de Bruno Latour,
qui est un éminent
écologiste,
qui dit que l'Europe est seule
mais que seule l'Europe
peut nous sauver.
Nous conclurons,
si vous le voulez,
avec le peu de temps restant,
sur cette question.
Monsieur Schellekens,
parmi les solutions
envisagées actuellement,
lesquelles vous paraissent
à privilégier au niveau
de la Commission européenne :
la fin de l'indexation du prix
de l'électricité
sur le prix du gaz ;
l'augmentation des capacités
de stockage du gaz
et de l'électricité en développant
la filière hydrogène ;
l'augmentation de la production
des énergies renouvelables
et du nucléaire ;
un acheteur européen unique
et la création
d'un grand marché européen ;
refonder de fond en comble
le marché de l'électricité
et, pour ajouter
une cerise sur le gâteau,
est-ce qu'il faudrait pas créer
un fonds européen mutualisé
pour l'énergie ?
Et pour tout ça, vous avez
deux minutes, pas plus.
A vous, monsieur Schellekens.
*Rire
*-Je vous remercie !
-Vous voyez,
on a entendu votre rire,
d'adhésion ou critique,
mais en tout cas,
vous avez la parole,
on a malheureusement peu de temps,
mais enfin quelles sont
les priorités pour vous,
grosso modo,
si vous étiez à la manette,
et avec un coup de baguette,
sur quoi votre action
porterait immédiatement ?
*-Les deux objectifs principaux
restent les mêmes :
l'indépendance par rapport
aux importations russes
et la transition,
la transition énergétique vers...
vers la neutralité
climatique pour 2050.
Donc pour reprendre vos questions,
on travaille déjà sur plusieurs
de ces questions.
On a déjà parlé de la réforme
du marché de l'électricité,
donc ça, on en a déjà discuté,
euh, nous travaillons en effet
sur une plate-forme
d'indexation de la demande
et la possibilité
d'achats conjoints, donc ça,
c'est déjà en route,
les négociations
sur cette législation ont abouti,
ne sont pas encore formellement
approuvées,
mais ont en principe
sur le contenu abouti, donc ça,
c'est en route, le travail
sur le stockage du gaz a été
une priorité pendant cette année,
le sera aussi l'année prochaine,
et notamment,
du côté investissement hydrogène,
où, je dois dire,
les signaux sont très encourageants,
avec de nombreux projets,
donc tout ça,
ce sont en effet des priorités.
Et alors,
pour revenir au nucléaire,
cela reste un choix national
et dans toutes...
dans tous nos modèles qui mènent
à la neutralité climatique
pour 2050,
il y a évidemment
une augmentation très forte
du renouvelable
mais reste aussi, dans ces modèles,
une base de nucléaire
à échéance 2050.
Ce sont des modèles sur lesquels
nous nous sommes basés
quand nous avons lancé l'objectif
de la neutralité carbone.
Donc, pour vous dire,
nous travaillons
sur tous ces relais,
il n'y a pas un volet
qui permettrait
d'oublier les autres.
-Brièvement, vous savez,
il nous reste très peu de temps,
vous ajoutez ou vous retranchez
quoi,
Christine Goubet-Milhaud ?
-Je trouve que, au niveau européen,
y a pas de politique énergétique
sans politique industrielle
et j'insisterais sur ce volet,
car en effet nous avons des atouts,
l'Europe,
avec des réseaux
de distribution performants,
des compteurs communicants
déployés,
dont nous pouvons tirer
sur la flexibilisation
de la demande le maximum,
en revanche, nous importons encore
beaucoup de produits,
que ce soit sur le solaire ou sur...
Nous avons encore une industrie
éolienne en Europe, donc moi,
j'insisterais beaucoup sur le fait
qu'une politique industrielle
européenne est absolument clef
pour qu'on tire
le meilleur de cette transition
énergétique.
-Monsieur Erkki Maillard ?
-La priorité, c'est d'avoir
plus d'électricité décarbonée
et moins d'énergies fossiles,
pas seulement du fossile
importé de Russie,
moins de fossile en général.
La part de l'électricité
dans le mix stagne,
voire descend,
ce qui est très inquiétant.
Donc oui, on a beaucoup d'atouts,
notamment industriels,
on doit mettre l'accent
sur la réduction de la demande
et la production d'électricité
décarbonée, ou on n'atteindra
ni la sécurité énergétique,
ni la décarbonation
de nos économies.
-Juste une question très brève,
qui vous concerne directement :
est-ce que vous avez confiance,
est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est faisable
qu'EDF remplisse
son programme nucléaire
tel qu'il a été proposé
par le président
de la République ?
-On fait tout pour.
-Vous faites tout pour.
Sur la question européenne,
Jacques Percebois,
vous ajoutez quoi comme priorité ?
-Faire baisser le prix
de l'électricité
en subventionnant le gaz utilisé
pour la production d'électricité,
qui à prélever des surprofits
pour le faire.
Il faut à moyen terme
réfléchir à un nouveau design,
soit un système d'acheteur unique
avec des contrats à long terme
permettant de couvrir
les coûts fixes et coûts variables
des centrales par des systèmes
d'appel d'offres
tout en laissant un marché
pour le court terme et les échanges.
-Armand Laferrère,
qu'est-ce que vous ajoutez ?
-Il faut,
il faut construire.
On préparera pas l'avenir
sans construire
de nouvelles capacités,
alors dans toute l'Europe,
dans toutes les technologies
décarbonées,
la France a déjà lancé
le mouvement pour construire
des réacteurs nucléaires,
mais ça ne suffira pas.
-Vous êtes prêts, à Orano,
dans le mécano, à assurer...
-On est prêts à assurer.
On a décidé comment on allait faire
pour les réacteurs,
mais tout un cycle autour,
dont ma société s'occupe,
va nécessiter des décisions.
Mais y a pas que la France
ou le nucléaire,
y a du nucléaire hors de France,
d'autres technologies,
il faut maintenant que les Européens
construisent l'avenir de leur propre
production énergétique.
-Ecoutez,
il me reste à vous remercier,
mais, avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Alors, un pavé,
si on ose dire,
Jacques Percebois,
vous avez écrit ce livre
avec Jean-Pierre Hansen
et Alain Janssens.
Bon, y a tout, là-dedans,
c'est la bible.
-C'est une synthèse des différents
types d'énergie, absolument.
-Une synthèse des différents
types d'énergie.
Je voudrais signaler également
cet ouvrage de Bernard Accoyer,
"Une affaire d'Etat".
C'est un pro domo,
c'est vraiment
le souhait que la filière nucléaire
soit la plus brillante possible.
Est-ce que vous avez
publié récemment
une étude à l'Union française
de l'Electricité ?
-L'Union française de l'Electricité,
avec tous ses adhérents,
suit le rythme de consultations
et de propositions
des différents conseils
européens pour être utile,
sur cette réflexion autour
d'un cadre de marché
qui nous permette de réussir
cette transition énergétique.
-Monsieur Schellekens,
est-ce que vous avez
un ouvrage à proposer
au niveau
de la Commission européenne,
ou de vos proches, ou de vous-même ?
*-Moi, je n'ai rien publié du tout
mais je serais très intéressé
de lire les ouvrages
qui viennent d'être cités.
-Merci,
monsieur Maillard ?
-Je recommande la lecture
des scénarios énergétiques de RTE,
qui sont très bien faits
et qui mettent à plat
les hypothèses économiques
et techniques
pour prévoir le mix de demain
de façon très sérieuse
et dépassionnée.
Je recommande vivement la lecture
au moins du résumé.
-Exercice qu'on pourrait faire
au niveau européen,
d'ailleurs, je pense.
-Merci de vos précisions,
merci, madame,
merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé à cette émission,
fort instructive,
sur une question d'actualité.
Merci à l'équipe de LCP
d'avoir permis
la réalisation de cette émission,
à la fois à Paris et à Bruxelles.
Et, avant de nous quitter,
je vous suggère cette réflexion
de l'Institut Bruegel :
"La crise de l'énergie représente
"le plus grand risque systémique
pour l'Europe."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA